au cœur du bâtiment éventré les services
de secours sont à pied d'oeuvre pour
tenter de retrouver des survivants sous
les décombres de cet immeuble
d'habitation à Oman la vie ukrainienne a
été touchée cette nuit par demi-cils de
croisière selon le gouverneur régional
l'un d'entre eux s'est écrasé sur cette
résidence au sol entre les gravats et
les véhicules incendiés les habitants
sont sous le choc
[Musique]
les secours extirpent les premiers corps
les frappes de cette nuit ont déjà fait
plusieurs morts
le camarade de classe de ma fille vit au
9ème étage de cet immeuble
je ne sais pas si Dieu le veut ils sont
vivants c'est une grande tragédie
le ministre de l'Intérieur ukrainien
s'est rendu sur place
selon des données préliminaires 109
personnes vivaient dans le bloc qui a
été détruit il y a 46 appartements dont
27 ont été complètement détruits
depuis plusieurs mois l'Ukraine dit
préparait une contre-offensive destinée
à repousser les forces russes des
territoires qu'elles occupent
actuellement dans l'Est et le Sud